hello again everybody once more it is
time to get into this adventure that we
call try not to laugh and when we don't
laugh we're never gonna laugh again
because laughing is the only thing that
brings us joy in life and we want to
make sure that there is no joy there is
no happiness there is nothing waiting
for us in the darkness that's sad okay
let me try it a little less depressing
now hi guys my name is markiplier ready
to not laugh me too cuz my life is a
vacuum of despair okay Edwin sad again
so the point of this video is not to be
sad its to not laugh hi whatever enough
[ __ ] I don't know it's good enough
let's go for this come on I wasn't
laughing I was breathing very rapidly
just like that thing was Oh barely
through this
[Music]
oh I've seen that before so it doesn't
count
since I've seen it before that's out of
this works right Jesus [ __ ] mugged
good bet the waterfall ability yeah oh
my god Bobby what dialects is that Jesus
[ __ ] mug goodbye the waterfall yeah
dialect is there
[Music]
okay I like sticks let me smash please
no Ron
go find Becky you want some [ __ ] no Ron
I don't want something I got your blue
hey girl you want some tail
Ron your tail is small I swear you'll be
sweetie you want the yellow blue and
yellow no Ron I'm leaving what no wait
let me smash what's my life come to
Becky thought my tail was big
Becky using a let me smash look Becky is
smashing Ben Ben is a hunk imma get back
there to stick pictures love stick
[Music]
snitch stick got stick back here I got
stick legs man I've seen names that I've
never seen I didn't think it was a video
don't make a thing
[Music]
[Applause]
No
[Music]
five big American PPF
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ok I'm done all right so I lost as usual
what else is new I think I lasted longer
than last time but honestly who cares it
still lost but if you want it home
congratulations you didn't laugh you did
it very proud of you but if you laughed
at home I'm so sorry you just got too
much joy inside you I guess anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know if you enjoyed this one down in
the comments below I had a lot of fun
with this one it was a lot of good stuff
in here and if you want to see another
one of these let me know that as well I
got a dig for videos again but it's
always worth it those few good ones guys
it's worth it so thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye